Précedemment dans " Qui veut gagner du Pilon ? ".
Dans la chanson popularisée par la Star-Academy...
Qui a volé l'orange du marchand ?
Je vais dire réponse E...
Je dis pas c'est qui, je poucave aps.
C'est votre dernier mot, Sabrina ?
C'est le dernier mot que je vais dire, c'est la réponse E.
Et bravo, Sabrina !
Vous gagnez pour une valeur d'un million d'euros de bon gros pilon !
Félicitations !
Merci, t'inquiète frère !
De quoi laisser croquer la milfa, évidemment.
Nous sommes de retour avec Rudy...
Pour " Qui veut gagner du pilon ".
On est là.
Arrivera t-il à égaler l'exploit de Sabrina la semaine dernière ?
Rudy, vous allez bien ?
Ça va.
Très bien.
Nous jouons donc pour une quantité de popo équivalent à la somme de 48 000 E.
La question est toujours la même...
Dans la chanson du 113, Jackpot 2000.
Quelle est la rime pour la phrase suivante...
Le physio qu'est à la porte ne parle pas un mot français
2m10, un clando..
Un beau morceau, mais ce soir, c'est sûr qu'il y aura...
Ça date aussi le 113 hein... C'est...
Je vous rappelle qu'il vous reste un joker.
Un appel à un ami.
Ouais, ouais je sais t'inquiète, je me souviens.
2m10, un clodo...
C'est sûr qu'il y aura du...
Bisso Na Bisso.
C'est votre dernier mot, Rudy ?
Non, non, non c'est pas ça.
C'est de beaux morceaux.
Donc votre réponse c'est qu'ils font rimer de beaux morceaux avec de beaux morceaux.
C'est exactement les mêmes mots, on est d'accord ?
J'avoue c'est sale mais le 113 il faisait comme ça à l'époque.
C'est votre dernier mot, Rudy ?
Ouais c'est mon dernier mot, vas-y, vas-y...
Dans Jackpot 2000 du 113...
La rime est...
2m10, un clando, un beau morceau.
Mais ce soir, c'est sûr qu'il y aura...
De beaux morceaux ! C'est une bonne réponse, bravo !
Je suis fier !
Je suis fier de ouf !
Rudy, on joue maintenant pour l'équivalent....
De 72 keus de beher...
Voici la question.
Oh le piège putain, c'est dur.
Vous avez le seum, là.
Pire que le seum, là.
Je vais utiliser mon dernier joker, je vais appeler un ami s'il vous plaît.
Vous souhaiter appeler un ami, Rudy ?
Ouais, pourquoi tu répètes tout ce que je te dis tout le temps, comme ça ?
Au calme.
Alors quel ami souhaitez-vous qu'on appelle, Rudy ?
J'aimerai appeler Askip, voilà.
Alors on appelle tout de suite votre ami, Askip.
Ouais, il a intérêt à répondre ce fils de pute,
il a rien à faire de la journée, il est au RSA.
Ça devrait aller.
Ouais c'est qui ?
C'est moi, c'est Rudy !
Wesh alors.
Eh ask'ip t'es à l'émission Qui veut gagner du Pilon.
J'ai vu tes snaps, là.
C'est quoi cette émission qui pue la merde,
qu'est-ce que tu fous là-bas ?
Bonsoir Askip, c'est Jean-Pierre Foutleseum.
Non ! C'était pas du mytho ?
Des barres !
Askip, votre ami Rudy a une question à vous poser.
Ouais.
Asy, on est là.
Askip, voilà c'est quoi la question...
Le verbe "bicraver", c'est du premier groupe...
Du troisième groupe...
C'est un verbe qui se conjugue aps...
Ou bien, c'est ta mère que je vais conjuguer ?
Attends, t'as dis quoi sur ma mère, t'es sérieux là ?
Non, mais c'est dans la question, c'est...
Toi, ferme-ta gueule, ferme-ta gueule !
Rudy, t'as dis quoi sur ma mère, t'es sérieux ?
Tu fais le bonhomme, là ?
Tu fais le mec menaçant parce que t'es à la télé ?
T'es un fou, tu me connais pas ou quoi ?
C'est pas moi.
J'te baise, sale pute va !
Eh, mais il me crache dessus ! Mais c'était la question aussi !
Il est un peu...
Pas sûr que votre ami vous ait beaucoup aidé, Rudy.
En même temps, il a cru que j'avais mal parlé sur sa mère,
c'est normal qu'il ait le seum.
Mais maintenant il va me falloir une réponse, Rudy.
Donc je vous repose la question...
Mais arrête avec tes...
Tu rends ouf à répéter tes questions tout le temps !
Je vais répondre, c'est la C voilà, ça se conjugue pas.
C'est votre dernier mot, RUdy ?
Mais oui c'est mon dernier mot ! Vas-y ouais, c'est bon.
Vous êtes déter, vous avez l'air déter.
Je suis déter.
Lorsqu'on utilise le mot "bicrave" on le conjugue...
Comme un verbe du 1er groupe.
Désolé Rudy, c'était la réponse A.
Bravo quand même Rudy,
vous avez été un excellent candidat.
Bravo, bravo quand même...
Je le savais en plus, je me suis fait bolosser par l'autre enfoiré,
mais je le savais.
Vous repartez quand même avec le premier palier.
1500 E de bon gros teshi.
De quoi vous mettre ienb.
C'est terminé pour ce soir, rendez-vous demain pour une nouvelle émission de
Qui veut gagner du Pilon.
Peace la famille.
Ah je suis vénère, je suis vénère.
Franchement Jean-Pierre, je suis pas bien.
Bah 1500 E de weed, c'est pas mal non ?
C'est de la merde !
Tu me feras créquo un peu ? Parce que j'ai plus des masses.